لبنان الآن في مأزق سياسي بعد أن فشل
رئيس الوزراء
المكلف سعد الحريري بعد 266 يومًا من
محاولته تشكيل حكومة جديدة
، التقى برئيس لبنان
ميشيل
الخاص لمدة 20 دقيقة ولم يتمكنوا من الاتفاق
على تشكيل حكومة جديدة
احتوى على 24 فردًا وصفوا بأنهم
متخصصون وتكنوقراط بدون
حكومة جديدة ، يستمر الاقتصاد اللبناني
في السقوط الحر
، فقد فقدت العملة المحلية خلال
ساعة ونصف
من الإعلان عن عدم تمكن الحريري من
تشكيل حكومة
فقدت 10٪ من قيمتها.
في شكل رهيب
أه تقلص الناتج المحلي الإجمالي أكثر من 40
بين 2018 و 2020
وهذا العام يتوقع وفقًا
لأمر مصرف البنك الدولي
أيضًا أكثر من
ستة بالمائة الآن ما نشهده
نتيجة هذه الأخبار
المتناثرة على الطرق حول بيروت
أه وأجزاء أخرى من لبنان
حيث أن هذا البلد يدخل مرة أخرى في فراغ
سياسي
أنا بن ويدمان.